pour eux le faste du Grand Théâtre de
Tournai qui ont des corps en trompe
l'oeil depuis plusieurs mois les
musiciens de l'orchestre symphonique
protestent contre la précarité de leur
situation au point d'annuler un
spectacle le samedi dernier une première
mais avec quelles effets on fait le
point avec notre invité ce soir bonsoir
Laura Perrine Martin bonsoir vous êtes
musicienne oboïste c'est ça à
l'Orchestre symphonique de Tours vous
êtes 55 musiciens alors vous êtes en
colère car on le rappelle nombre d'entre
vous tous en fait sont en ne sont pas en
CDI et ce quel que soit votre ancienneté
on va y revenir mais d'abord une
délégation avait rendez-vous ce matin
avec le maire de Tours l'un des
financeurs à la mairie de Tours pour lui
faire part de vos revendications qu'en
est-il ressorti
malheureusement
notamment
les que la mairie s'engage à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de licenciement d'ici un an
parmi les toutes les équipes du Grand
Théâtre de Tours c'était un des points
et un autre point important c'était que
la mairie remette ses subventions un
niveau suivant le cours de la de
l'inflation sur les 20 dernières années
et malheureusement sur ces points quand
même assez cruciaux on a eu aucune
réponse de la part de la mairie on fait
un petit retour en arrière pourquoi
est-ce que vous craignez des
licenciements quelle est la situation
financière aujourd'hui de l'orchestre
alors la situation financière est très
compliquée faut savoir que depuis 7 ans
les musiciens nous subissons une une
grosse grosse baisse d'activité en 17 18
saisons 17 18 on était à 61 concerts
maintenant on est passé à 37 sur la
saison en cours on remonte légèrement à
40 concerts pour la saison à venir mais
voilà pour nous c'est extrêmement
compliqué d'un point de vue artistique
et financier étant donné que nous sommes
employés en
cdduré déterminés sans indemnité de
précarité vous êtes payé à la série de
concerts c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
pour le parure répétition et concert en
fait on a des cddus et ce qui fait que
du fait de ces statuts dès que le grand
théâtre a des problèmes rencontres des
problèmes financiers en fait l'orchestre
se retrouve avec une variable
d'ajustement mécaniquement et donc ça
fait un an qu'on alerte l'ensemble de
nos tutelles sur cette situation
dramatique la mairie partager à défendre
auprès des autres tutelles le passage en
CDI à temps complet pour l'ensemble des
musiciens mais pour ça il faudrait que
votre activité augmente que l'orchestre
joue à plein temps c'est ça et c'est pas
du tout le cas aujourd'hui vous pensez
qu'il y a des possibilités aujourd'hui
de jouer à plein temps nous on le pense
parce que c'est le cas partout ailleurs
en France à chaque région a au moins un
orchestre permanent à temps complet et
on le pense d'autant plus que la que la
région vient de faire un geste important
pour
réaugmenter l'activité artistique des
fins 2023 et ce qu'on espère c'est que
les autres tutelles aussi bien notre
employeur que la DRAC département le
ministère de la Culture s'engage aussi
dans ce sens en vue d'augmenter
progressivement pour atteindre le temps
complet parce que quand on se penche
dans le détail sur votre situation
nombre d'entre vous n'habitent pas tout
ça peut être assez étonnant mais c'est
précarité vous oblige à habiter un peu à
l'extérieur exactement
du fait de notre en fait on est
intermittent alors certains sont
intermittents du spectacle d'autres
cumulent avec d'autres emplois mais du
fait de la précarité de ces statuts on
ne peut pas c'est difficile pour nous de
nous engager à temps complice surtout
malheureusement c'est ce qu'on
souhaiterait alors ça bouge un petit peu
quand même puisque la région vous
accordez une rallonge de trois
spectacles supplémentaires c'est bien ça
plus que ça trois séries supplémentaires
donc on peut envisager avec deux
concerts par série peut-être bon pour le
moment c'est pas encore défini mais
peut-être en tout cas au moins 6
concerts supplémentaires et oui c'est un
effort que l'on salue et ce qu'on salue
c'est que la on sent une envie de cette
tutelle que peut-être bah de développer
notre orchestre justement et c'est ce
vers quoi s'est engagé la mairie mais
voilà on souhaiterait que maintenant
d'un point de vue financier ça bouge
aussi de ce côté là est-ce que votre
mouvement de grève qui était une assez
inédit à donner quelque chose à porter
ses fruits
ça a porté alors bon c'était un
crève-cœur d'en arriver là
malheureusement on le regrette vivement
ça a porté ça nous a permis de
rencontrer Monsieur le Maire Emmanuel
Denis aujourd'hui voilà c'était c'est la
première fois qu'on le rencontrait et on
leur remercier et mais pour le moment en
fait si si aucun argent supplémentaire
n'est débloqué rapidement en s'oriente
vers des licenciements et ça voilà c'est
c'est ce qu'on veut éviter à tout prix
on attend des réponses on attend des
réponses merci beaucoup Laura Perrine
Martin est devenu ce soir sur notre
plateau